c'est une manifestation rare qui s'est
tenue hier à paris plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de policiers ont manifesté leur
colère
deux semaines après le meurtre du
brigadier éric masson à avignon et
quelques jours après l'agression d'un
fonctionnaire dans la loire à l'appel de
quatre syndicats de police les
représentants des forces de l'ordre de
toute la france se sont rassemblés
devant l'assemblée nationale
un lieu symbolique avec un objectif
interpeller la classe politique
les fonctionnaires réclament un plus
grand soutien notamment financier ainsi
qu'une plus grande sévérité de la
justice à l'égard des agresseurs de
policiers gendarmes et pompiers
elle sait nous sommes rassemblés ici
c'est surtout pour nous de ton dénoncer
les conditions de travail
asus important dans lesquels on
travaille on est surtout mis les
violences des violences dont nous sommes
les cibles quotidiennement c'est pour ça
que nous nous voulons des actes il ya
tous les élus qui sont là qui se font
une tribune politique qui sont venus moi
je demande à tous ses élus au delà de
leurs clivages politiques d'aller dans
notre sens pour faire en sorte que les
réponses pénales soit très ferme
immédiate s'il faut légiférer y avait
beaucoup d'élus c'est leur rôle de
travailler à l'assemblée pour faire en
sorte que les policiers soient
respectées et considérées
mais une bonne fois pour toutes pensons
aux collègues sur le terrain quitte
l'hymne à longueur de temps qui sont
régulièrement blessé tout le monde en a
marre donc le gouvernement doit prendre
conscience de la situation parce que
nous on va continuer on va pas lâcher
des policiers qui ont été rejoints au
cours de la journée par de nombreux élus
de toutes sensibilités
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin s'est également déplacé une
importante présence politique dénoncée
par certains comme opportuniste à
quelques semaines d'échéances
électorales afin d'éviter toute
récupération l'intersyndicale s'est
opposé aux prises de parole à la tribune
mais les élus présents ont tenu à
s'exprimer pour répondre au ras le bol
des policiers
nous avons commencé à dialoguer avec eux
lundi dernier lors d'une intersyndicale
avec laquelle nous avons dialogué
nous allons continuer semaine après
semaine pour chercher à apporter les
solutions qui permettront à chacune et à
chacun d'aller vers ce but commun qui
est la protection des français
rétablissement des peines planchers le
mandat de dépôt systématique lorsque
vous
touché aujourd'hui à un policier qui est
une exception ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
les forces de l'ordre lorsqu'elles sont
agressés recroise bien souvent leur
agresseur dans les semaines qui suivent
la volonté de les protéger aujourd'hui
par le droit en instaurant une
présomption de légitime défense
beaucoup de mesures que nous avons
longtemps porté dans le débat public et
qui sont aujourd'hui portés c'est vrai
par les forces de l'ordre et que nous
mettrons en oeuvre à la tête de l'état
jean castex a déjà fait un pas en
direction des syndicats lors d'une
réunion le 10 mai dernier à matignon
mais après les annonces du gouvernement
les policiers attendent à présent des
avancées concrètes